so we actually wore fireproof overalls
during the event I mean that's not so
appropriate now but everyone within the
boundary was supposed to wear these and
to stop being on fire and fortunately
they were not necessary so they're
actually oil rig workers boiler suits
other
a work of genius clearly crazy insane
genius where did it start where did the
idea come from and how'd you get going
with it some years ago I was fortunate
to get to go to Burning Man and I saw
lots of fire out there I thought that
sounds like something I kind of want to
do so I've had this thought in my head
for a while to do that two years ago the
previous EMF camp we did a big
collaborative project many members of
the space contributed and we made Barbot
which is a cocktail making robot and
when it came around to this time I
thought maybe do something with fire I
was down London and having a drink with
John T when the EMF organizes and I want
to ask him if it was okay to do fire EMF
because it's kind of potentially risky
and his response was yes yes it is in
fact he'd already been sort of
experimenting with these sorts of little
flamers and he suggested pong as a game
and so we just sort of took it and ran
with it and sort of came to fruition
that way there was lots of
experimentation lots of broken things
mainly arduino pro mini x' went through
a food four eight five drivers as well
is something not quite right with their
dad to start with yeah
blend out a few bits of electronics one
of the things we had to work out how to
do was how to light the gas so we
experimented with things like barbeque
lighters but they weren't really that
effective but I came across these things
one pound 64 from eBay he put five volts
in you get a few thousand volts out and
then another challenge we had was how to
design a spark gap when you did we need
some insulators but ceramic tubes were
really expensive to buy so got a couple
of ceramic tubes from fuses here with
the screws in the ends and a machined
aluminium block would just mount through
the right position we initially just had
round-headed screws in here that we
found that we didn't get as a good spark
between them and the actual high voltage
generator is wearing out so we did a bit
of research found this at sparks forum
better off sharp points so we at least
little strands of wire here which just
encourage it to generate a spark and it
also means that the spark is over the
end of the weather where the gas comes
out it was it difficult to make the game
work as a game rather than the
engineering
side of it was that very straightforward
yeah we didn't know if it would actually
be fun to play when made it I mean I
just wanted things to be on fire so
didn't really care too much about the
sort of actual gameplay until quite late
in the process and it turned out it kind
of worked pretty well and it was more or
less my first sort of implementation of
a game of pong which was really a
placeholder for something a bit more
sophisticated but it sort of worked so
we just built around that it was a bit
of description about what would happen
when you one wasn't there you know we
didn't want to encourage people to lose
we didn't want to encourage people to
win so that was when the victory swipe
came was ensue to faster to encourage
people to want to want to win and to
have that extra go and make more fire
when you win people really enjoyed the
victory swipe I think it's a successful
strategy well I want to say about expert
plumbers but we certainly learned an
awful lot about different gas fittings
on this project if some of the nuts some
of the joints the left hand in some of
they were right-handed and a lot of its
Imperial quite a lot all of this section
that's all on what's called quarter-inch
BSP vowels but nothing is actually a
quarter-inch quarter-inch was what used
to be the inside diameter when they have
very thick walled pipes but now and
lighting bike a quarter-inch bsp pipe
and quadrants BSP fittings and there's
no measurement on there that is actually
a quarter inch which is really really
weird it's very satisfying to put
together because it's really heavy and
chunky you know I'm a software guy by
trade so one of the challenges we had
was all the gas hose are left-handed
threads but a lot the other fittings are
right-handed threads one of challenge
was trying to find the missing
components which allows to convert from
left-handed to right-handed and that
took quite a while trying to get that we
found a source them weren't cheap but we
did find the source of those we did
actually have a few parts custom CNC
made as well the adapters for the butane
tanks into the rest of the pipe work the
thread on a butane tank is not something
which is
generally you can't buy parts which go
into it basically there's the kind of
valve that comes with the cylinder and
that's the only thing that goes in so we
ended up having a part CNC made by
another hacks based person and that
worked out pretty good so the
distribution board is actually split
into two so we have 2 separate pressures
and the main supply comes in here and we
run this up to 4 bar and so we have a
full bar gauge here and then there's a
second regulator here and for the small
purpose to come off and that has a
separate pressure we actually want them
to run as low as possible and because we
get a nicer quality of flaming more like
a sort of torus of flame and then you
get the smoke ring coming off it if it's
at low pressure
if you've run at a higher pressure you
tend to have a sort of turbulent flow
and it doesn't look as sort of visually
appealing and so we can set the pressure
of the large buffers and the small
puffers completely separately just by
adjusting this and the other regulator
which is actually on the tank so small
puffers of the yes exactly they're the
the puck is how I think of it sort of
going back and forth the fire pixel
pixel voxel there's room for a
spoonerism there this is the source of
the propane so this is running
everything it all comes in through this
distribution board to the other parts of
the system the other two canisters are
actually butane cylinders which were
discarded and they act kind of like a
gas capacitor they're called
accumulators and they store gas close to
where it comes out so that it can come
out quickly
from the top of the accumulator we come
through this solenoid valve and from
there it's just 22 mil pipe straight up
to the end of the barrel and the idea is
to get a fast flow of gas up to where
it's burning so you get a nice big puff
if we didn't have the accumulators what
would happen is the rate of flow would
be constricted by the width of these
pipes and these are only 5 mil propane
tubes so you can't get much gas through
them and in fact after we've discharged
the accumulator you can hear it
recharging for probably about a minute
or something until it's back up to full
pressure
and so that just bait it enables us to
have sort of a sudden big flow of gas
and make a good big flame we've got a
separate regulator on the side which
powers the pilot lights we've got the
constant flame there it's quite nice we
took is the EMF camp festival so it
gives us put a bit of ambient light
around the whole area the game is really
intended to be played at night and so
that the obviously all the fire looks a
lot better when it's dark but the pilot
lights give a kind of a really good base
level of illumination with everything
sort of flickering and it adds quite a
lot to the atmosphere while people are
queuing up and then when you get the big
puffs the sudden change in brightness is
kind of visually appealing the
scoreboard kind of gives us an option to
actually display something so we can get
an idea of what the state of the game is
this is helpful when we're selecting
mode so right now it's saying this is
sparks mode there various buttons on the
control box let us select mode so setup
it's kind of a nested menu yeah this is
the gas distribution board we try to
build in accordance with Burning Man for
our guidelines and one of the things
that they say you have to do is to have
a single master cutoff valve which is a
coarse term valve so you can quickly
shut off everything which kind of works
except they're still gassing the
accumulators but it works to prevent any
more gas getting into the system and
then we can also isolate individual
segments so each large puffer has its
own valve and similarly each of the
three small puffer segments also has one
of these and then it's all as brightly
indicators as possible so that we can
see it at night and under the flickering
lights of the pilots and which worked
fine we didn't have to mess with it at
all the serve 60 amp hour spire in here
so when everything's ruining it could
tend to take 50 54 amps or a bit
concerned about that consume that how
much chromed it's using so looking
around hack space look if your meter
came across a box of all sorts of meters
we found this one which is got it's got
feet per minute on it but it's actually
calibrated with a shunt in here so it
actually reads nought to 60 amps but he
never goes more than about 20 amps at
the most when it when it's running 600
feet for a minute that's actually means
60 and
yeah yeah I guess so yes yeah guess so
so a quick look inside here say so
inside we've got that's the 60 M power
supply that creates 12 volts and these
teas can were just stepping down to 5
here which powers the Raspberry Pi which
is running running everything and then
we've got a hours for it 5 converter
here virus for it fires a differential
network so it's more immune to noise
that's right well we got it we've got a
high voltage out there on the sparkers
and we also got very high current as
well so because we've got high code
froze cables we will get a voltage drop
and we're concerned about the ground
level shifting so using 4 8 5 which is a
differential signal which goes between
norton 5 then 5 and naught as the data
set down the line that's more immune to
noise than RS to the 2 which is a
single-ended system it's under raspbian
and then the actual applications written
in and python yep it's all Python on the
Raspberry Pi and the actual
communications is done like I said over
a and sort of custom serial protocol
which just describes events it's only
one directional so it just sends events
there's no acknowledgment that an event
has been processed in one of the various
nodes but we've set it up so that
there's not an event to say turn the gas
off now so it may be the event doesn't
trigger some gas coming out but it
should never just leave our valve open
and pouring gas everywhere in that
protocol we have a checksum so in case
there's noise from the sparkers or from
the high current we can detect that the
packets being corrupted and not trigger
an event so in this way we try to be as
kind of robust and safe as we can
yeah that's the found that's inside the
palace planets creating all that noise
it was off from eBay and probably from
China Ogura guess but in quite reliable
that ip65 were integrated connectors so
make sure everything out there was water
people just use the same connectors on
on on the control box and the pins in
here 8 to 30 amps would potentially gots
like 20 amps in each segment and then
we've got these 4 control buttons that
just wind into the GPIO pins on the
Raspberry Pi for controlling it yes yeah
arcade buttons that's it yeah most the
time it's just the yellow button is to
restart the game isn't it
yeah that's for the most part once it's
in pong match mode we require a manual
interaction to start the game going and
then the game will proceed until it's
finished and then it sort of weights
again for other interactions so the
operators have a time to describe to the
players what they're supposed to do and
so we have a little should be all that
we give people about have a practice
raft of the baton the the bats have a
haptic feedback from the wheeler they
vibrate slightly when you want them to
sort of indicate that you've actually
done it right because you have to give
it a little bit of give it a little bit
of welly to sort of make the Wiimote
detect and it was a bit much for some of
the smaller kids back to come nearly as
big as then yeah well what's the name of
that rule zero is a hax based thing so
rule 0 for hax base is do not be on fire
and it basically means look after your
own safety and look after the safety of
other people around you you're
responsible for your safety that's the
sort of gist of the rule rule 0 the game
has an asterisk next to it which
basically says what the guideline yeah
so yeah I was a bit of a bit of a play
on the hex based rule that's a good call
in the game area we haven't got anything
definitely lined up but I've had some
interest but nothing come
yet I'm sure we'll run it again it's too
much for a single event Oh remember in
any ours I think we started working on
it in earnest about two or three months
before EMF and we've been planning for a
long time and some little bits of
prototyping yes quite what was it wasn't
there does it cost you artists a fair
bit I mean we got some money from EMF
EMF has grants for projects yeah and so
many plotting PACs fans buzzing back
space also yeah and give us some funding
but didn't quite cover all the costs
literally burning money yeah the
cylinders 28-pound I think to refill of
sillman and that lasted about four hours
at the EMF capsule of half eight to one
half midnight yeah so every night
these are actually pieces of metal studs
which you just got from a DIY shop yeah
this kind of box-section thing and
that's just to keep the pipe work from
twisting in terms of sort of make it as
stable as possible so that we don't end
up getting sort of leaky pipe work so we
want to keep it all rigid and it also
lacks is a nice conduit for the various
pieces wiring stuff first they do
actually stand up on their own but we
put the legs on just to sort of make it
much less stable you don't know if the
ground is going to be level where we're
running it so there's just some
butterfly volts on the top there which
you can loosen and then the feet will
sort of twist in so that it's easier to
put in the car the setup process to get
everything sort of in place and
connected to the gas cylinder totally
about half an hour but then we have a
process that we need to go through to
flush the connectors
there's no air in there and that process
protects another 1529 so I'll be an hour
from sort of putting everything on the
floor to actually having a fire
happening obviously if you're doing it
in public we also need to set up fencing
so EMF camp we had a whole bunch of
pedestrian barriers which we sort of
laid out in a perimeter around the
flames and we try to have a five meter
distance between any of the anything
that can make fire and members of the
public so that was quite a big perimeter
so take a little while set those up but
yeah it doesn't take too long to put
together its they ain't gonna wait for
dark if you're indoors it's horrifying
when we were testing those in the hack
space it was actually unsettling to be
anywhere near them people would visually
back away I think thousand volts per
meter of gap if you're gonna get arcing
so probably five six thousand volts
which is amazing we put five volts in
and thousand times that comes out it
takes quite a few amps at 5 volts to
actually empower them but one of the
challenges was getting enough power to
be each individual segment so we have
quite beefy cables to be able to deliver
that much power there are many ways in
which fire phone can hurt you I think
the sparklers are the bit that I'm the
most frightened on I like the fire this
was made by another nothing hack guy
called jelly and he participates in the
project by making these yeah the first
one that we made has twice as big and
you could barely lift it but these these
are pretty great this is where
participants were smacking it on the
fencing that was in front of them
got a bit enthusiastic when alcohol is
involved yeah so it took a bit of a
beating but they've they've held up
pretty well
it surprised you when you've been making
this done everything
yeah one of the challenges that we have
was cooling of the LPG so inside of the
tank the propane is a liquid and then as
you let the gas out it boils inside the
tank so you get a phase change and the
liquid cools down really rapidly and you
can actually see that on the tank that
it starts to frost pretty quickly so
here you can see that's kind of the
level of the propane in the tank so
we've got through about you know a third
of a tank so far it's a problem because
if the temperature drops too much then
you get a drop in the amount of pressure
you can produce so when it gets down to
about numbers if it's minus 20 Celsius
then you get down to about one and a
half bar which isn't enough to really
drive the big perfective Lee so when we
were running at EMF camp we actually had
this submerged in a big vat of water and
that just helped to keep it warm enough
to keep the pressure up oh but it's
amazing how quick this effect happens I
mean like we have been running for a
little while and you can see the frost
on there but if you're running it hard
this happens really rapidly and you get
a drop in pressure so you know I think
you're missing a trick this is that
combined with Barbara's we the drinks
cold we did actually cool areas at EMF
camp in the big vat of water anything in
the pipeline for next time we have some
ideas but we don't know what yet depend
depends on the site maybe more fire yeah
fire is good you want to contact you
about its project thanks base yep yeah
we've got lots of details on the noshing
hack wiki including pretty much a
comprehensive list of all the parts that
we used and how much it cost and where
all the things from obviously don't
encourage people to set themselves on
fire
remember rule zero and but yeah if
people are interested you can find lots
of information there and if you post a
notting hack mailing list then you can
you can get in contact with us that way
we get is an incredibly weird picture of
sort of weird hybrid baby things that
kind of gives me nightmares
you could argue in some ways we're
getting an intuition about what the
lower levels do and what the high levels
do predominantly it's just for fun